- What even is mince meat
and why would we want to put it in a pie?
(guitar christmas music)
- I hope it's not liver.
- It's made of mince.
- [Man] And what's mince?
- I have no idea.
- Oh boy.
- This has some nice weight to it.
- The crust looks nicely done.
- I like the little
sugar sprinkles on top.
- It has three holes in the top.
- I don't even know how to
get it out of the container.
- We don't want to litter up our whiskers
with a bunch of pie crust.
- First time ever.
- Now that's interesting.
- The crust is good.
- Chewy.
- Tasty but it's dry.
- The top of the crust is
very crumbly, very good.
- Raisins and I'm not sure, some cinnamon.
- I'm enjoying the taste
and the sensation
and the texture.
- You know it tastes a little bit raisiny.
- But you need something
to drink with this.
Maybe some hot chocolate
or some hot tea.
- What the hay?
- That reminds me a Thanksgiving pie that
my mother used to make
years and years ago.
- I would revisit these.
- This is a treat that
we have to teach more
American households to make I think.
- This was an excellent pie.
- Don't look at something and
say ew, ick, I don't like it.
Try it.
- Very good, very well done.
- So if you're thinking of
putting out something for Santa,
a little mince pie.
(Santa laughing)
I love it, thank you.